so i grabbed the suafer man for for nick
and um
i'm holding it in my hand the camera
knows i took it off the shelf
did you have to tell the camera and how
much work is it to onboard
each sku each of these unique items how
do you do that it's a lot of work
a lot of work absolutely yeah i mean
it's not trivial we need
tens of millions of pictures of what
this thing looks like in every possible
configuration
that's that's the quantity that you need
to be able to train tens of millions
tens of millions
it's nuts it's it's a lot how do you
take ten
tens of millions of suave men pictures
is it just that i hold it and we walk
around with it
and you take all those pictures and a
human so we have a whole i mean a lot of
this gets into the
super competitive advantage of how we do
data creation
but yeah we have a massive laundry list
of what we call data creation which is
how we
how we want to put each possible product
in every possible configuration
just that is a research project that
we've been doing for years is figuring
out what
configurations this product should be in
got it uh but then we just have cameras
that are collecting streaming
we collect millions of these pictures
yeah i mean if you just had
i don't know what a thousand people
coming in on the store and pretend they
were buying
each of the items and each person took
10 of the items you had 100 people do
each item
that's enough training data that's
exactly the right idea yeah
and you can send that training data to
two human beings in africa or india or
wherever manila
and people get paid a dollar an hour
which is probably triple what they would
get in any other job and they can just
sit there
highlight and say yeah that's this we do
a lot of clever hacking to
double blinded even uh you can do a lot
of double confirmation quality assurance
yeah and we do a lot of clever stuff so
that it's as legal as possible
even before you get to a human got it